fresh off the presses famed bond
investor bill gross's monthly investment
outlook where he says the reality of
today is that and I quote because this
is perhaps my favorite line in the whole
report not even thin gruel is being
offered to our modern-day Oliver Twist
investors you have to pay to come to the
dinner table and then sit there staring
at an empty plate in other words you're
paying Germany for example to hold your
money right now well what does this mean
for the health of the investing world
what does it mean for the fed what does
it mean for pension plans what does it
mean for you Janice capitals Bill Gross
joins me right now bill welcome back
it's great to have you back on the show
Thank You Trish I guess I anytime you
can work Dickens into an investment
letter along with a few references the
Westminster Dog Show my hat goes off to
you thank you here's another one you
know back in the Depression in the 1930s
humorist Will Rogers said that he wasn't
so much concerned about the return on
his money but the return of his money
and in today's financial markets worked
as you mentioned two trillion dollars of
euroland paper trades at- yield some as
much as minus 75 basis points I think
Will Rogers would have to be concerned
about both a negative yield assures the
investor that not only is the return on
its money or her money unsatisfactory
but the return of her money will be less
than he paid you know it's pretty crazy
and you got investors bill out there
that are getting somewhat desperate
right for yield because you rightly
point out there's there's just none out
there so theoretically let me ask you
could that change should it change do we
anticipate that Yellen will raise rates
in June well I think that's part of the
problem although it's one that can't be
easily diagnosed in terms of historical
models did you get to the extent that
interest rates at the zero bound in the
United States you know promote higher
stock prices higher bond prices you know
some of that trickles down to the real
economy and you know promotes growth but
to be fair not much has you know what
has been promoted has been you know
potential bubbles and
stock markets and in bond markets and I
think the Fed is willing at this point
to at least acknowledge that by raising
interest rates 25 basis points in June i
also think and this is important Trish
that the the interest rate can't be
raised substantially even over the next
two to three years I mean the market is
anticipating a two percent fed funds
rate in 2018 late 2018 and I I think the
reason that they can't is that the US
economy and the global economy to which
the US dollar and the US interest rate
basically serves is the two levered to
highly levered just too much debt and
ultimately two percent is probably that
the top in terms of this Fed cycle let
me ask you though how bill does yellin
and company get off of the zero interest
rate policy at a time when the US dollar
is showing so much strength you talk
about you know the currency war
effectively that we're seeing right now
that nobody wants to call it that but
how can the Fed move when the dollar has
already rallied as much as it has
against other currencies well I think
that's a really good point and I agree
with it obviously I put that in my
investment outlook you know what a
stronger dollar does promote you know
some negatives it promotes not only
lower exports and then lower growth in
terms of manufacturing but it promotes a
an infusion of deflation as opposed to
inflation which is exactly opposite that
what the Fed wants to do today's number
Trish the personal consumption index you
know on a year-on-year basis was at one
point one percent and going lower and
their target is two percent so
ultimately that's again one of the
reasons why you know if they get off the
dime in June or if they get off the dime
in September that they basically have to
go very slowly because ultimately a
stronger dollar promotes lower growth in
the United States as opposed to
haier group you mentioned this lack of
inflation one point one percent versus
what they'd like to see two percent do
we need to be worried about deflation
clearly it's a concern overseas is that
a reality that we could be facing well I
don't think so in the United States I
mean for the most part are our inflation
index is outside of oil and outside of
food prices you know basically reflect
health care expenses and wages in the
united states which are going up by 2%
themselves so the united states that
appears has escaped this you know this
trap this liquidity trap the euro land
in japan are in but you know not
necessarily for all time and so you have
to be worried about it now no but i
think if the Fed truly wants to get to a
two percent inflation rate which by the
way is the reason why they need to get
there is that in a an ensuing recession
or slow down they need some room to
lower rates and so you have to fit
eventually gets to two percent inflation
then that's probably the sweet spot for
Janet Yellen you say eventually two
percent I mean how long is it going to
take for that to unfold do you think
these are going to be very slow moves
bill I do you know I basically think you
have 50 basis points a year right now
the forward market as I mentioned is
anticipating at two percent fed funds
rate in late 2018 so that's three and a
half years whether or not that's the
proper path the proper the slope and in
terms of a forward yield curve no one
really knows but it gets back to you
know what I talked about in april of
last year you know the new neutral rate
the new policy rate which ultimately in
my view has to be much lower than
historically because of high leverage
and because of demographic influences
that basically promote lower structural
growth you know bill Danny Yellen has
ended
that she's going to stay patient but
here we are what six years in deserve
you've had multiple rounds of QE and all
we've got is this anemic growth in your
view has the Fed been too patient I mean
do you worried all that it's policies
have actually had the unintended
consequence of causing people and
companies to delay purchases because
they now money is going to be cheap for
the foreseeable future yeah I think they
went too far Trish and that's a you know
a a subjective assessment of history I
guess but a zero percent interest rate
yeah induces positives in terms of
higher bond prices and stock prices but
also some negatives you know it keeps
zombie corporations alive because they
can borrow it three and four percent as
opposed to eight or nine percent it
destroys business models it's destroying
the pension industry and the insurance
industry because you know basically
their liabilities can't be can't be
provided for by very low interest rates
and ultimately I think it destroys the
you know the capitalistic model at the
margin you talk about stocks and cheap
money you know basically corporations
instead of investing in the real economy
can now simply borrow at you know close
to zero percent and buy their own stocks
which yield two or three percent on a
dividend basis and you know provide a
return of six or seven percent on a
earnings the price ratio basis so you
know there are a lot of negatives in
terms of zero bound interest rates and I
think one of the reasons why the fed
will move is to to sort of gradually
move away from those negatives yeah it's
given birth to all this financial
engineering but you wonder these days
whether investors are really valuing
assets for what they're worth let me ask
you with that in mind you ever worried
that the Fed is just perhaps too
forthcoming in its information
as well I mean they seem to want to tell
us everything and anything that they're
going to do and I just wonder whether
investors have become overly reliant on
that telegraphing from the Fed I mean
the ever long for the days when you
actually had to wait and check the
markets to see what the Fed had done
back before it was as transparent as it
is now well I don't long for that day
because it was it was very uncertain and
you waited on a Thursday afternoon or
morning to see whether or not the Fed
was you know changing its interest rates
on a weekly basis but I think the Fed is
moving away a little bit from this from
this certainty from Draghi's whatever it
takes from you know basically alerting
the market as to you know how high
interest rates are going to go and what
level they should be at so and I think
that's a reflection of Stanley Fischer
he basically wants to move away from the
certainty model will see a little of
that movement but I I'd like to at least
to know a little bit about what the Fed
is thinking in terms of you know new
neutral interest rates where they think
you know the the neutral interest rate
should be relative to the Taylor rule
which they used prior to the recession
to the Great Recession in two thousand
and eight and nine let me let me ask you
this is the first time you and I have
talked on air here since you made your
move to Janice you were founder of pimco
your name was synonymous with that firm
what's it like being someplace new after
having spent your career your entire
career elsewhere well it's certainly
different do you know pimco had 2,500
people Janice Newport you know basically
has seven or eight although Janice
Denver a much larger location and much
larger larger corporation you know has
thousands of people too and and so it's
a little bit different there's more
flexibility basically and what I'm doing
the unconstrained funds that are run on
a separate account basis and the mutual
fund so there's a lot more flexibility
there's the ability to to move as
opposed to
not move so much as was the case in
pimco so you know a little bit smaller
certainly but a little bit more flexible
and I enjoy that you know a lot of
people would have said look I don't need
to do this I got plenty of money I've
had plenty of success why keep going why
I get up and go to the office every day
and do what you do at this point well
part of it you know my wife said she
married me for a better or worse but not
for lunch and that's oh so lunch time
has spent a newport beach but also you
know I wanted to show clients and to
show the world to the extent that
they're interested you know that I can
continue to produce a track record like
I did at PIMCO you know I won't have as
much time I won't have 5 to 10 to 15
years of leeway like I had a pemko in
terms of proving that but certainly for
the next two three or four years you
know I'm a very competitive person and I
like to post numbers that are better
than the market and better than the
competition so it's it's a combination
of both of those well my congrats evil
grows great to see you hope to see you
again soon